we've actually figured out a way to
quantify record quality back in the day
there was it was impossible to do that
now we can take signal-to-noise ratio of
the electrical signal off the records we
can count pops and clicks and sound
artifacts just because something too old
or doesn't necessarily make it inferior
the only difference you're gonna find
from our records to a record from the
1970s is our records are a little bit
flatter and it sound a little bit better
we took the traditional process of
making records and we've modernized it
the biggest thing that we thought was
exciting was the where the automation
parts of the machine that allowed one
technician to run up to four one
warm-toned presses every single possible
variable is controllable and
programmable from our interface it
allows the operator monitor every single
portion of the process
we're offering what is being proved as
an average of 1 1 vinyl press for 30
seconds with an opportunity with the
right environment to get down to about
22 seconds we get a higher yield off the
press for a few reasons
we've improved the consistency of the
melt by reengineering the screw and the
extruder we've improved the way the the
puck or the free mold is is transported
into the hydraulic ram that's more of a
solid foundation that was a traditional
pain point of some of the older presses
to transfer it to the to the cutting
station we use a vacuum system to pick
the mold up from the label instead of
using a traditional means of picking up
the record by the flashing right now we
have two machines and they're going to
be able to produce what about six to
eight of the old machines were able to
produce and the old machines was
typically a 30 to 40 percent yield loss
the warm tone record presses under 1%
meaning if you're making a thousand
records instead of recycling 300 or 400
those records you can actually deliver
those to the customer which just makes
the timing much much faster it makes it
less expensive for both the artist and
of course for us as manufacturers I
think this is just such an important
event that's happening that should
really expand and excite the artist
community this is an opportunity to
really get the sound that they're asking
for as the uptick in vinyl sales have
started what we've seen is there's been
some really healthy margins for the
independent artists so we just saw it as
a great opportunity to really tie the
local scene in the independent music
scene to this really big need which is
which is vinyl records which we've seen
from our end as one of the only ways
that that independent musician can
really make money in the digital space
now they can actually sell their music
again rather than just renting it
you